ucrania se prepara para lo peor este
miércoles el parlamento aprobó el estado
de emergencia más el estado emergencia
se impondrá en todo el país excepto en
las regiones de donges elegans los
guayaneses con las autoridades podrán
imponer restricciones de movimiento
bloquear mítines y prohibir partidos y
organizaciones políticas desde el
ministerio de seguridad y defensa
alertan que los partidos pro rusos están
desestabilizando el país internamente
además ucrania va a movilizar a 900 mil
reservistas de entre 18 y 60 años y
urgió a sus ciudadanos a salir de rusia
mientras tanto el presidente de
volodymyr selenski insistía en pedir
ayuda a occidente nosotros estamos
defendiendo con el apoyo de nuestros
socios pero es el pueblo ucraniano el
que está muriendo y ucrania necesita
garantía de seguridad a los llamados de
ayuda que llegan hasta las naciones
unidas- ucrania alerta que si no se
impide el avance ruso afectará la
seguridad de toda europa aunque todavía
confían en una solución
la diplomacia activa los mensajes
políticos fuertes las sanciones
económicas y el fortalecimiento de
ucrania aún puede complicar a moscú
abandonar los planes agresivos
esto se produce mientras eeuu a alerta
que el 80% de las tropas rusas
desplegadas están en posición de ataque
estas se cuentan en 150.000 efectivos
también letonia advierte de que éstas ya
habrían entrado en el este de ucrania el
kremlin aseguró que don jet-ski lugansk
le han pedido ayuda con tropas el líder
independentista de donges pidió más
temprano la retirada de las fuerzas
ucranianas
somos conscientes de la amenaza de las
nuevas armas que se han suministrado a
ucrania últimamente el conflicto centra
todas las miradas en el mundo mientras
en rusia se celebran los últimos avances
muestras de solidaridad con ucrania se
extienden por los países occidentales